foreign
are we rolling right now oh is this the
beginning of something yeah here we go
tonight The Young and the Restless
celebrates the 50th
50. I mean it's a lifetime
[Music]
the cast sits down to share revealing
stories from the set take that to your
grave we'll we'll talk about how I got
this job crazy and the scenes that ended
up on The Cutting Room floor take it
easy I just love making out it's all in
a day's work how the show pushed
boundaries I had a summer where I was
bulimic I had a summer where I was
addicted to diet pills and I overdosed
there was bullying and of course there's
excited crying baby drinking Melody
Thomas Scott can cry like that it's
cake
from the Epic fights to the famous
alumni How You Like Me Now 34 years I'm
still learning lines we've been number
one in daytime no one else has come
close to it
BS presents The Young and the Restless
50th anniversary celebration and
Entertainment Tonight special
welcome everybody to a very special
golden anniversary 50 years of The Young
and the Restless we're here on this
iconic set the Abbott family living room
where so much television history has
gone down I'm talking more than 12 000
episodes
159 Emmys and 35 years as daytime's
number one drama May 18th 83 take one
in fact I think maybe I'd be better off
dead than alive
you are not going to get
mine you want this chair
[Music]
have a seat on me
but really what we're celebrating is
five Decades of family and tradition
you'll hear fun stories from pregnant
mothers who say you know I would watch
the show every day and and then when my
baby was born or toddlers you know what
they'd walk to the screen when they
would hear the music that they heard
this song in the womb
so tonight we're taking you behind the
scenes to the heart of Genoa City for
all the romance the drama and the family
that is ynr starting with the legends
that have been a part of it for almost
as long as the show has been on the air
yes 43 years
how lucky am I well I'll be now
congratulations never did I think that
this would last beyond three four months
I love it best role I've ever played Mr
Braden is uh he see that Mr Braden
he is massively intimidating and
absolutely lovable at the same time the
funniest thing is if Eric Braden gets
the giggles oh my gosh it's so funny and
he just can't stop some of the best
bloopers that we have on the show is
when Eric like has an extreme case of
the giggles and it's hysterical to watch
he and Josh will just last for hours
he'll start up
and then you start to see his shoulders
go and then we're all laughing who knows
what do you hear from my co-stars I have
no clue but we laugh a lot you know
I want
I want it
Melody Tom Scott is also another icon I
I literally can't believe I hit the like
emotional Power Ball of parents on this
show
worry about your father we have an
arrangement so he knows about you and
Arturo
oh no this is uh from Tuesday February
20th 1979 which was my very first day on
this show I remember the talent test
that took place about three days before
my first day I was pretty blase because
I didn't really care if I got the part
or not now hearing me say that like what
an idiot I was I adore her you know I
just love working with that door what
are you
is Right 125th anniversary
my first day on ynr was uh 32 years ago
like crazy Jack I don't believe it oh
believe it honey smiling jackets back in
the flesh
you want to touch me be my guest Peter
Bergman is a legend eat a burger you
look like a fine specimen
a fellow named Terry Lester had played
this role for 10 years to great success
I was here for about a year and a half
when I won my first Emmy in this role
and that kind of sealed it for me I I
think I realized yeah I guess this is
mine now
he's my older brother in more ways than
one cares deeply about the show about
its success about the actors about the
crew you know somewhat of a leader of
this show he's like the mayor of Genoa
City he connects to everyone he works
with so I actually saw him out one time
by accident just you know ran into him
and he looked exactly the same as he
does on the show just his hair is just
so presidential picture his hair is like
a daytime treasure I mean I don't know
how he keeps it like that hello
and he rubs his hands through it and
you're like oh something amazing is
about to happen
at the hair yeah
the rug
but have you ever wondered where it all
began well the idea came from the late
William and Lee Bell the husband and
wife team's original working title the
innocent years a secret is good
characters good stories and have
characters that an audience can relate
to romance I think is very important and
then a little bit of excitement Romance
contagious our parents are Bill and Lee
Bell together they created The Young and
the Restless in 1973. getting close to
the end of the line for me get away City
and here we are 50 years later with my
sister Laura Lee who's been on the show
how many years I started Cricket
in 19 I'd say 83. these are our parents
directors chairs these will forever
be with me Bill and Lee Bell were
obviously Giants in their industry
nobody could do it better we were so
fortunate to have Bill create and write
for so many years he knew the pulse of
Genoa City Bill Bell and we're going
back almost 32 years asked me to bring
my babies to the studio and to work with
me because he knew then that I would be
able to concentrate on my work and I
would feel safe because my babies were
on set it was just incredible to have
them here I've been told that Cassie was
the last character that bill Bell wrote
The Bells you know created
such iconic television this was their
baby and whenever they cast somebody
it's like they were adding another
member into their family Lee was indeed
a presence on the show at that time Lee
had helped bill create all this she of
course was a legend in her own time in
Chicago my mother had her show on the
air live every day in Chicago so he
stayed there for us one of our jobs was
to take the carbons out of the carbon
copies of the scripts to fold them up
and to lick the envelope and put the
special delivery I think it was like 60
Cent stamps three of them which was very
expensive at the time and that's how the
scripts would come to Los Angeles by U.S
mail only recently did I hear that the
show was not doing well at the beginning
were you aware of that when why it was
and he was frustrated and he said let's
just let's just end it and the network
said oh we have a contract it's not
going to end it's you know we're going
to we're going to fix it and it was like
rebuilding a whole new show but he was
determined and
it paid off it worked that's when it all
turned around
he knew the value of conflict and high
drama and luring in the viewer and
luring Us in too
Dylan is
my son
I would think the fence coming back for
the drama
of drama for some reason I'm talking
everything you've done to me and my
family I'm telling you it was an
accident
Feud with Victor is
something I'm incredibly proud of 44
years Jack and Victor have been mortal
enemies people love to
see the clashes of two
powerful businessman I want you to get
your things and I want you to get out
one of my favorite moments with Victor
Newman he was yelling at Jack who's in
his office and uh suddenly
seized his heart
fell to the ground and Jack chose to
leave on my way to the door his body was
lying there
and I don't know what overcame me I
kicked his hand out of my way
and they got it the cameraman got it it
was it was just deliciousness kick of a
dead hand I cannot wait until the day
you dropped dead another iconic
decades-long Feud loved by fans
Catherine Chancellor and Jill Abbott I
intend to give her one hell of a fight
it's about 21 years coming for their
relationship they've hated each other
for a very long time
we had so much fun so much fun it was
all about the comedy really with Genie
and me we'll just dad live it out and
then I head inside
she's a nasty woman the nasty woman
whenever I'd see her and I knew she was
going to be in scenes with her I knew
that I was gonna laugh the whole day
well give me Chloe
my grandchildren they love that cake
scene so much she was trying to grab the
whole cake to put it on me it was just
hilarious we did one take and then we
just laughed and laughed and laughed
[Music]
looks like you lost control Nikki
people say to me my God how can you play
one character for so many years but it's
like playing different people that
they're all wrapped up into one
you like my disguise what are you doing
[Music]
favorite part of being Nikki well
I guess everything God knows I have been
asked to do just about everything tell
him that I have to go I have to go my
first month on the show
uh my father tried to rape me and I hit
him over there the lamp and he died
then I got involved in a prostitution
ring then I ended up in a cult then I
became a stripper
I was stripping at this sleazy horrible
Club where I met Victor Newman I do have
a scene one of my top favorites everyone
thought that Victor was dead I know
that's happened more than once and Nikki
is absolutely devastated she is
literally sitting at his grave I didn't
give out anything
in the world to have you bag anything
and then he speaks to her she thinks
she's hearing things she turns around
she sees him
that was one of the top yeah Victor and
Nikki have had quite the love story that
includes getting married to each other
four times I'm an incorrigible fool
no you love me
well it's my 13th wedding uh what's
yours I have no idea I'm suffering from
amnesia
I've been to more weddings as Jack
Abbott than I have been to as Peter
Bergman it's true you can't think Y and
R without picturing the Epic weddings
and over five decades there's been more
than 100 ideas which means we've seen
some pretty gorgeous gowns
Phyllis and Nick got married four times
their second wedding I really loved that
wedding dress that was Monique lilier
and that's that's something I would wear
this is my dress what I love the most is
that there's a pleated cotton tool I've
never seen cotton tool before
now which was your favorite dress that
you wore 1984 first wedding to us
stunning beautiful 30 pound gown
how much is this dress worth well the
last I heard uh twenty thousand dollars
buy it rolling reporting five four three
two why in our weddings are big they're
very beautiful that scene where Sharon
and Nick dance together at their wedding
we were young and we we were very caught
up in it it was really special
I cried when she came down the aisle for
our wedding
it felt like I was getting married for
real and I was married in real life at
that time
I had to deliver my vows at literally 10
minutes to 1am and they were pulling the
plug at one there are a lot of vows so
there and it was long
we've done lots of weddings on the show
and they're tough days it's a lot of
people to Wrangle it's just it's chaos
but with the terrariah wedding that day
was so different my heart is
racing it's a celebration and that's
really the best thing that that you can
have when you have a same-sex couple on
television is just celebrated to Mariah
and Tessa
[Music]
if you have a soap opera without love
and romance I mean it's not a soap opera
in my eyes
I will tell you my favorite thing to
play
as an actor and inflated quite a lot
falling in love I love you damn it and I
want you to be my wife
my wife is a saint
my wife has watched me fall in love as
Jack with all of these women it's a lot
I walk sometimes with Mary Ellen and
someone will say you and Phyllis are the
perfect couple I'm standing next to my
wife
miles and she says I love them too
thank you I sure will
Michelle Stafford is so in the moment as
an actress bad check bad
why are you hopping in the sack now
we're lonely and it's something to do
you know
it's funny because I used to when I was
younger love doing love scenes look at
this
cult
just loved making out
now I just go oh gosh okay I have to
have warning for a love scene and I'm a
little more self-conscious Now isn't
that strange and you would think I'd be
less self-conscious with age
Phyllis doesn't sweat that much well and
it's all in a day's work
[Music]
we have a very interesting job where we
come to work and sometimes get undressed
instead of dressed and just everything
nice way of putting it and every now and
then I think
what do I do for a living
[Music]
what the steamy scenes are like
when I started I was a little nervous
about them because there's a million
people watching um but you know there's
really nothing sexy about us shooting
them in the moment now where do I go
right here
it's very
choreographed so we get the best shots
excuse us we're gonna go get sweaty and
do our jobs
we often
often sweaty if you know we're doing a
love scene it's better than screaming
and crying at eight o'clock in the
morning which is what I'm usually doing
when I'm here
okay Q uh can be tricky there are
certain times it's a lot easier than
others it used to be horrible for me
sorry
I would try everything I would put a
lemon in my eye I
if I see Josh or Sharon cry I will be
reduced to a puddle of tears I honestly
think about my children
and I think about good and happy things
with them I'm going to start crying
right now Melody Thomas Scott can cry
like that
I get sick sort of satisfaction out of
doing it my job is keeping tears down my
I'm a crier
oh yes Peter gets emotional it's lovely
I think
thank you
I think of my very happiest memories
here's your son
[Music]
just happens
his name was John
her water has broken Summer's birth was
one of the craziest things I have ever
done
still get crazy thinking about it
no I have to push come on jacket stuck
with Phyllis in an elevator and has to
deliver a baby
Peter Bergman had to sit between my legs
the entire time I remember that and and
the baby the the newborn babies that
they make they put jelly on them and and
condensed milk that's what I remember
speaking of remembering each cast member
needs to memorize up to 70 pages of
dialogue for each day of filming shoots
can last between 10 to 12 hours and they
gotta deliver five to six episodes each
week
I'm very honest with you I sometimes go
in the sudden I said I don't know how
the hell I'm going to do this and then
you do
my trick in learning lines is I have a
little diptophone it's this little
recorder and I read in my scenes all of
your lines
leaving an opening for my lines it works
for me I can fill the gap
I tend to memorize about 85 percent of
it and I make up the rest the amount of
dialogue is so large it's astronomical
and you get one take it's great working
in offices sometimes because you know
I've been known to write a couple words
down every once in a while where they
escape me it's cheating I guess there's
no reason to tell you what you already
know you open your drawer and you look
at your lines and then you put them back
in and then you go back five four three
two cut look in your line okay five four
three two
that's how I do it I had my scripts on
set like everywhere everybody does oh
absolutely this is my set by the way
this is my living room and uh I jammed
my script right behind the pillows you
pulled them back they'd be like
50 scripts there's probably scripts from
1987 in this couch right now
[Music]
foreign